[Musique]
bonjour je suis
sourde et je m'appelle i s A B e l l e
Isabelle voici mon
signe vous allez
bien moi ça va il fait beau temps le
soleil
brille j'ai envie d'aller me
promener un entendant tiens là on va
voir comment il s'y prend pour m'appeler
moi qui suis
[Applaudissements]
sourde
madame oh
[Musique]
madame
mademoiselle ah c'est pas bon me jeter
une boulette non c'est absolument pas
respectueux de moi qui suis
sourde ça ne va pas on lui donne une
deuxième chance on va
voir
voilà ça c'est bien m'appeler de cette
manière là c'est respectueux voilà en
tant que personne
sourde
bonjour
bonjour ça
va ça
va ça va ça
va moi je suis très content de vous
rencontrer
oui il est content de me
rencontrer une personne sourde
bon bon on va le laisser hein voilà bon
il est content de me rencontrer moi je
suis aussi content de rencontrer une
personne
entendante oh qui se calme quand même
hein à bi à bientôt au
revoir je suis
sourde il est
entendant
bonjour ça
va il fait
beau
content
rencontrer à
bientôt au
[Musique]
revoir